upstairs upstairs
scenes of panic on the outskirts of the
danish capital
people ran for their lives as shots were
fired in the fields shopping mall
witnesses said people hid in shops
terrified as a man walked round with a
hunting rifle
it's pure terror this is awful you know
you might wonder how a person can do
this to other human beings but it's
beyond beyond
you know anything that's possible we
didn't know what to do so we ran
people were guiding us towards the exit
sign and then
we ran up the roof and were stuck there
for a while and then people were
panicking all over the place and people
crying
armed officers were quickly on the scene
as were paramedics and firefighters
police arrested a suspect in the
immediate aftermath of the attack
describing him as a 22 year old ethnic
dane and saying that several people had
been killed at around 1am local time the
streets around field shopping center
were still blocked off as police held a
press conference to update the number of
dead and wounded
police say the motive was unclear and
would not rule out what they called an
act of terrorism
we have a situation where we have three
dead it's a man in his forties and two
young people
the shopping centers just across from a
subway line connecting the city centre
with the international airport
tourists arriving into the country were
held away from their hotels near fields
until late into the night
while a concert by pop star harry styles
was at first given the go-ahead after
organisers spoke with police before
eventually being cancelled
the suspect in sunday's shooting will
now face a judge for questioning on
monday
paul reese aljazeera copenhagen